tech companies have laid off tens of
thousands of employees but they've also
handed out hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of servants to each and
every employee that was laid off Mata
offered a 16 weeks of base pay plus
another two weeks of base pay for every
year of tenure Google offered an
identical package but some companies
took it even further Salesforce for
example offered a minimum of five months
worth of base pay and that's just base
pay itself most Severance packages also
came along with the stock vesting
through the current quarter or more six
months of health insurance the
opportunity to cash out PTO and a
compensation for the 60 day notification
period so most of the people who were
laid off from Big Tech walked away with
nearly six months worth of full
compensation this is no doubt how seven
should be handled if layoffs are
required but were these layoffs even
worth it I mean these companies are
basically committing to paying these
employees for the next six months a
director for example would walk away
with 400 to 500 thousand dollars not to
mention they never even stopped hiring
yes we always see headlines about Google
or meta implementing a scary indefinite
hiring freeze but this isn't actually
true while hiring it is definitely
slower and more selective Google
literally has over 1900 job openings
posted as we speak so if these companies
are just hiring back new people as they
lay off their existing staff work
exactly is the cost savings sure they
can pay the newer people a marginally
lower salary of 10 or 20 percent but for
a company like Google or Microsoft
saving 10 or 20 percent on 10 or 20 000
employees is a rounding error not to
mention all of the terrible PR I mean
just look at Apple they're coming off as
some sort of Heroes for not doing
layoffs while meta is presented as
suffering from typhoid fever or
something so join me as we figure out
just how much these companies are
actually saving from layoffs and the
real reason they're resorting to layoffs
foreign
let's start off by taking a look at the
supposed benefit of layoffs reduced
operational expenses given how much
these companies pay the apparent savings
are actually quite large Google for
instance has a median compensation of
295 000 Facebook comes in just under
that at 292 000 these are already big
numbers but that's just direct
compensation of base salary stock and a
bonus these companies also hand out
extremely generous insurance plans 401K
plans retirement Plans free food
smartphones monitors phone plan software
subscriptions airline tickets hotel
rooms and office spaces they also have
to pay social security and Medicare tax
on these salaries as well so the
indirect compensation itself easily adds
up to another 50 to 100K let's call it a
100K to give these companies the benefit
of the doubt this means that the average
employee is costing Google and Facebook
roughly four hundred thousand dollars so
how much exactly are the layoff saving
well Google has thus far later after 12
000 people and Facebook has laid off 21
000 people at 400k Pop Google is saving
4.8 billion per year and Facebook is
saving 8.4 billion per year this was the
first time that I started thinking that
maybe the layoffs were worth it I mean
we're talking about the billions of
dollars every single year that is until
I faintly recall that not a single one
of these companies are losing money in
fact they're not even remotely close to
losing money some of them are straight
up posting record profits and when you
contextualize these savings with just
how much these companies are pulling in
it just becomes even worse in terms of
Revenue Google pulls in just under 300
billion dollars per year and the
Facebook wasn't just over 100 billion
per year so the savings only equate to
six days worth of revenue for Google and
the 26 days worth of revenue for
Facebook obviously they haven't hit the
jackpot but with that being said savings
are savings why why make less money when
you can just make more money which
brings us back to the idea of maybe the
tech companies were right for doing
layoffs until you consider natural
attrition here's a secret these big tech
companies are actually really bad at
employee retention and it's not because
of bad pay or bad work culture maybe
with the exception of Amazon it's
actually because most Fang level Tech
Bros are simply not dependent on the
company a lot of them have enough money
to retire by the time they're 30. so
it's not like they're held back by their
job as such they're constantly looking
for better opportunities and leave as
soon as they can find one this is why
the average 10-year at most tech
companies is only two years for Google
this corresponds to an employer turnover
rate of 13 let me put that in another
way Google has to hire 25 000 people
every year just to maintain their head
account meta has to hire 11 000
Microsoft has to hire 28 000 and Apple
has to hire 21 000 and all of that is
just with a 13 turnover rate some of
these companies have turnovers that are
way worse which raises a rather
interesting question could these
companies have just stopped hiring it
and waited it out
foreign
well let's just say the minute that the
first big tech company announced the
mass layoffs this strategy became a lot
harder suddenly people are scared to
join that new startup or even switch to
another big tech company in fact I bet
the natural attrition is the lowest it's
been since like 2008 and that's all
thanks to meta who kicked off The Big
Tech layoff season back in November but
this isn't to say that this strategy has
become impossible I mean apple and
Nvidia are literally leveraging the
strategy as we speak but if all the big
tech companies weathered out the storm
together the strategy would have simply
been even more effective in fact it
would have negated the need for layoffs
altogether for many companies take
Google for instance they have to hire 25
000 people every year just to keep up
with the turnover this means that
instead of laying off 12 000 people and
giving them ridiculous efforts for 6
months Google could have just
implemented a real hiring freeze for six
months and they would have ended up with
the same headcounter and the same color
savings this idea is simply even truer
at Microsoft so far they've laid off 10
000 people but they could have just
Frozen hiring for four and a half months
in fact for Microsoft it might have been
cheaper to freeze hiring than do layoffs
and don't even get me started on Amazon
the attrition is so dang high that they
straight up measure it on a weekly basis
they lose three percent of their
warehouse workers every single week and
to be honest I don't think their Tech
turnover is all that much better the
reality is that for most companies
freezing hiring for six months would
have accomplished the same goal as
layoffs all with the better PR the only
notable exception to this would have
been meta who would have had to freeze
hiring for two years which just goes to
show how much they overhired but for
everyone else the situation wasn't that
bad also freezing hiring isn't the only
alternative there's plenty of other
Solutions like cutting bonuses out of
the average googler's 300 000 salary
about thirty thousand is just a bonus so
if Google had simply cut the bonus of
all 190 000 employees that itself would
have saved 5.7 billion dollars or 500
million more than layoffs also that's
not even considering that directors and
the VPS and Executives have
exponentially larger bonuses but Google
didn't even reduce bonuses they simply
delayed them another solution would have
been to offer early retirement and
voluntary resignations this is usually
what Southwest Airlines leans into
whenever they're going through a
turbulent period like the pandemic and
newsflash Southwest hasn't never had
layoffs despite having low single-digit
profit margins so if Southwest can get
through without layoffs tech companies
definitely can with their 30 to 40 net
margins the only argument against these
Alternatives would be that companies
give up controller as to who leaves with
the layoffs companies can slash certain
departments and titles but the this can
simply be corrected for with strategic
hiring if you want to get rid of
recruiters just stop hiring recruiters
with time things will level out how you
want but then if the savings from
layoffs are marginal at the best and
there's little Strategic Benefit to
doing layoffs what's the real reason
that everyone is doing layoffs
foreign
to get to the root of why companies are
really doing layoffs we first have to
identify who exactly wants layoffs it's
obviously not the employees but it's
also not the employers either do you
really think that these companies want
to be the bad guy they already have a
bunch of bad rep regarding invasion of
privacy data collection and
monopolization reputation wise one of
the only factors that are going in these
companies favor nowadays is that they
pay well and have happy employees so it
makes no sense to screw that up as well
not to mention all of the damage layoffs
caused the company morale and ongoing
projects Tech CEOs more than understand
this and that's why most of them don't
want to do layoffs
take Tim Cook for example he's taken a
pay cut from 265 million dollars in 2020
to 49 million this year similarly Zoom
CEO Eric Yuan has taken a 98 pay cut now
I'm sure it's hard to sympathize with
these billionaire CEOs oh no Tim is only
making 50 million this year boohoo but
bear with me the point is that these
CEOs are doing their best to prevent
layoffs themselves hold on back up what
do I mean they're trying to prevent
layoffs they're literally the ones
approving them well as far as the public
is concerned that's true the CEOs are
the ones who take all the blame and bad
rep for layoffs and they're definitely
by no means Saints but they're also not
the ones behind layoffs the ones who are
really behind layoffs are people like
this you probably have no idea who this
guy is because people like this lurk in
the shadows but they pull all the
strings this is Christopher Hahn the
founder of TCI fund management he's a
multi-billionaire with a six billion
dollar stake in Google and since last
November he has been constantly sending
letters to Sunder and calling out Google
amongst investor circles we are writing
to express our view that the cost base
of alphabet is too high and management
needs to take aggressive action the
company has too many employees and the
cost per employee is too high within
hours of this letter being sent Google
Shares were already up 4.4 percent that
doesn't sound like a lot but for a
company as big as Google we're talking
about a market cap increase of over 50
billion dollars making it crystal clear
that this is what Rich investors want
the reality is that people like
Christopher Hahn have it no idea about
Tech they think it's like some sort of
factory where you have to maximize
output and minimize input that's not how
Tech works and the tax CEO is obviously
know that but that's completely relevant
you get a dozen Christopher hunts
together and boom and Sunder or Tim
that's out of a job so naturally they do
as they're asked even though it's not
all that effective also I don't want to
understate the aggressiveness of these
investors after the first round of
layoffs at Google the first thing Chris
did was send in another letter asking
for far more he wanted Google to cut a
total of 40 000 jobs and reduce pay
substantially and Chris is just one
example most big investors do the exact
same thing just behind closed doors and
that's why everyone is suddenly doing
layoffs even though the effectiveness is
questionable to say the least something
else that's questionable is Goodwill's
Goodwill check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys